el ataque ayer en la ciudad de venecia
donde al menos 23 personas murieron y se
siguen buscando personas desaparecidas
bajo los escombros ha vuelto a crear el
temor en las grandes ciudades de ucrania
incluida que es la capital donde nos
encontramos sin temor a ser atacadas por
misiles cruceros ayer vinicio fue
atacada por tres de ellos de hecho se
habían lanzado cinco desde un submarino
en el mar negro pero dos de ellos fueron
interceptados ya días atrás había
sucedido algo similar en kif y también
en la ciudad de cría menchú donde un
centro comercial fue atacado esto ha
creado las alarmas entre las autoridades
y la población en kiev por ejemplo dos
tercios de la población ha regresado
desde el pasado mayo aquí la gente ha
vuelto a hacer una vida normal e incluso
es bastante peligroso porque cuando
suenan las alarmas como sucedió
constantemente en el día de ayer muchas
personas no buscan
en esos pasadizos subterráneos o en el
metro como solían hacerlo con
anterioridad lo que hace que haya más
peligro cuando se lanzan estos misiles
que tendrían como objetivo seguir
desmoralizando a la población ucraniana